these canals been around for about 150
years and about a year ago President
Sisi decided that he was going to
effectively try and double the amount of
traffic that going down it so we've got
a 72 kilometres second lane this is now
a two-way Highway the Suez Canal two-way
traffic will be allowed in as you say
it's taken about a year to complete at
one point 80% of the world's dredging
machines were here in Egypt Suez Canal
is absolutely key for the trade
especially between Europe and and and by
Easter I think the the way that we have
as a as an industry and with governments
backing has been comparing the the prior
issue has also shown how important it is
because it has actually not deflected
trade from passing the Suez Canal so I
think the Canales is absolutely
paramount sewer to the trade lanes
between Asia Europe but also - between
Asia Africa and even the US East Coast
I'm not sure the world asked for it but
it's possible that the world may need it
over time the question about the Suez
Canal is really related to its charges
so if you have a ship that's going east
west or west east you can either go
through the canal or you can go the long
way round round Africa and that's a
matter of cost so it's it's simply a
question of how much they charge if they
overcharge people won't use it